I was born in North Korea and not
knowing that I was born in the most
oppressed country I think that's how I
tell Americans when they said they're
oppressed like if you know you're
oppressed you're not oppressed like not
knowing is the definition of Oppression
I believe I was living in the best
country on Earth it was a socialist
paradise and I had this thing a song
called nothing to Envy because we were
living a socialist Paradise
so I I think with that just have no idea
what was going on in the world uh when I
was 13 years old I just couldn't simply
find any more food
so that led me to escape to China
then uh crossing the Gobi desert into
Mongolia after two years then go to
South Korea and then five years after I
came to America all while you're how old
it was from me 13 to 15 I was crossing
the desert and then come to America when
I was 21 years old that's unbelievable
you know when people hear a story like
that how often you know me when you tell
your story people almost don't believe
it they think it's like you're just
telling a story there's no way that
story is real yesterday I posted a
picture of me in the military and I post
a couple pictures in the Army and I'll
get messages people say that picture
doesn't look like you that's not you and
I'll say hey I was born and raised in
Iran and you know here's what Iran was
like when we're getting bombed there's
no way that's true you're just telling
the story out of Argo how often do you
hear people say you know you don't you
can't tell me it was that bad
so in some sense I think I got lucky
because a I mean remember when Americans
uh is tourists or one beer from the
Virginia Tech University he went to
North Korea and then he was sentenced
for heart live for 15 years for stealing
a banner
and then they tortured him and they
rearranged his Tech like old teeth and
then he came out of the vegetable state
that Trump like brought him back so I
think American understood like if that's
what they do to American white men yeah
I mean they can't even imagine what they
would do to their own people
so I think when it comes to North Korean
issue at least still the between
Democrats and the Republicans understand
the complete Black nobody argues it's
somehow great
and but how they want to approach some
of the problem is different so then then
you know for for some again the question
why are you so optimistic though you
know when I see you and I met you we
went to lunch afterwards you had very
nice things to say about Adam you
thought Adam was part of the lgbtq
community I don't know if you remember
this or not oh yeah
oh that was her that was her she asked
Adam if Adam's gay she said you said
you're very nice and you dress well so
you must be gay I was like I will show
you who's not gay right now you know
what I mean not that there's anything
wrong with that anyways but but we are
friends we're good but you were you're
always optimistic your personality you
seem like you were have the attitude of
future looks bright but then at the same
time you have the uh you know the
perspective you present of hey let's
stay paranoid because we don't know what
could happen here even in America how do
you balance that level of optimism with
the life that you've lived and have a
little bit of paranoia to say we got to
keep fighting for this freedom
I think in general
over 200 effects
say that one part again over the last 80
years only 209 nursing defectors may
come out over the last 80 years 209 have
made it to America that's intense yeah
yeah and I'm one of them wow that's
right and they made it pretty hard right
I mean it's now it's almost impossible
like they set up landmines and electric
fence and like he's it's made it yeah
it's impossible to get up that was
actually a question for you and me uh
the Escape process I know we have a lot
of stuff we want to get through today
but just the Escape process when you did
it how difficult was just that component
of it and how more difficult how much
more difficult would it be now
so my time was like every 10 meters with
the actual human guard with the machine
gun standing there every 10 meters it
was a human guard but now actually China
gave them the technology of the facial
recognition camera
everywhere on Chinese side and North
Korean side both they put the
electrified wire fences and they buried
the landmines to kill his own people and
then he actually put the people moved
away from the border towns okay so now
it's literally impossible literally
when's the last time someone escaped
ah like I don't know so keep the ones
that don't even let one single ant cross
between borders wow and when you escape
you said there was a soldier every 10
meters I assume you did it in the dark
how did you disguise yourself how did
you uh go under the radar so to speak so
the reason how I didn't get shot was the
people were helping me the traffickers
they were selling us to human
traffickers in China so they bribed the
guards but the problem was they're every
10 meters you cannot drive all of them
it's too expensive so they bribed one
guard and that post so we could always
shot from other posts
so that's why it was very dangerous so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]